lorsque l'on s'imagine une église on
pense généralement à une imposante
bâtisse de pierre grise dominé par un
grand clocher mais à compter de la fin
des années 50
certains architectes se sont amusés à
éclater les formes et à réinventer
l'église l'idée du renouveau liturgique
de l'église cet accueil célébrant soit
près de ses fidèles
donc ce qui a été beaucoup réinventer
c'est un peu la disposition toujours un
espace très ouvert
tout est simplifié comme langage pour
que les gens soient dans un espace qui
est le plus simple et dépouillée
possible souvent mis en valeur avec la
lumière ce qui donne l'aspect symbolique
de tout ça j'ai évolué le célèbre
architecte et canadien roger d'astous
qui étudié avec frank lloyd wright a
conçu plusieurs églises qui sont de
véritables bijoux de créativité et
d'innovation
las tout dans cette église le veut
d'abord se servir de la fameuse poutre
qu'on voit ici mais qui traverse à
l'extérieur pour insérer à la fois de
l'ornement mais pour porter une partie
de la structure puis il fait rentrer de
la lumière par différents d'ouverture le
développement de nouveaux matériaux
comme le béton armé a permis de
concevoir des bâtiments de formes
inimaginables auparavant
à l'époque les fermes modernes 101 très
innovatrice en tant que réalisation de
tout ce qu'on voit un dieu du toit en
fait ça se tient sur quatre colonnes
seulement donc on a un peu l'impression
que fait cette marche très lourde de
béton flotte au dessus de nous le génie
des créateurs s'exprime certes dans
l'architecturé des bâtiments mais aussi
dans les nombreux détails et accessoires
qui habille ses églises
c'est vraiment une vitrine où on
intercale dans le fond les différents
savoir faire que ce soit au niveau de la
menuiserie des sculpteurs des statuaires
mais chemin de croix les vitraux tout ça
on était fait et penser au même moment
où l'église a été conçu
mais malgré les dons des fidèles et les
sommes investies par québec plusieurs
églises la province sont en péril les
journées du patrimoine religieux
pourrait contribuer à changer les choses
le patrimoine fait partie de nos vies
mais des fois on l'oublié un peu mais si
on le connaît si on prend là
n 2 s'est intéressée de venir le voir
après ça on fait plus pourquoi on veut
une ambition d'être on dit qu'au québec
les églises sont au château au delà de
leurs fonctions religieuses elles sont
un attrait touristique
nos sondages montrent qu'après 15 % des
touristes au québec s'intéresse
fortement à cette question leur soit
l'angle du pèlerinage ou l'ample ceux de
l'architecturé la culture samedi et
dimanche 138 lieu de culte dans 85
villes de la province seront ouvertes au
public une idée d'activité dix villes
est gratuite pour la fin de semaine dont
il serait pécher de se priver
ici nabi alexandre charti radio canada
montréal